Roald Dahl's children's books have
inspired many movies over the years from
fantastic mr. Fox to Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory and the latest
adaptation is said to be bigger than all
the rest I'm Simon and this is your
entertainment news updates Disney has
released the second official trailer for
Steven Spielberg's upcoming The BFG the
first trailer revealed the Big Friendly
Giant but this one goes further
showcasing more action and setting up
some of the story The BFG is based on
author Roald Dahl's 1982 book it stars
Oscar winner Mark Rylance as The BFG
while newcomer Ruby Barnhill plays
Sophie an orphan girl who befriends The
BFG and has to face the Menace of other
far less friendly Giants in an interview
with the Toronto Star Spielberg spoke
about his decision to cause violence
after a single day's work on bridge of
spies for which Rylance won an Oscar I
knew he was my BFG he's such a contra
man actor and such a deeply sensitive
human beings The BFG opens on July the
1st 2016 it also stars Bill Hader
Penelope Wilton Rebecca Hall and Jemaine
Clement are you excited for the BFG or
are you tired of endless film
adaptations let me know in the comments
or come find me on Twitter I'm at the
jaqen or thanks for watching and for all
your entertainment news keep it gamespot